les merveilles de paris ce n'est pas
pour maintenant ce qu'ils vont voir en
premier de la france ce sont les hôtels
préfabriqués de banlieue le leur est à
30 km de la capitale dans le val d'oise
pour 30 euros la nuit ce soir il n'est
pas question de mettre le nez dehors
wang surtout ne sortait pas du domaine
de l' hôtel dans le centre de paris
c'est très joli le soir mais là nous
sommes en banlieue et ça peut être
dangereux
il ya des gens bizarres partout et ne
laissaient rien de précieux dans le bus
allez on y va
chérie le guide nous a bien dit de faire
attention à tout par exemple de toujours
porter un manteau ou une veste pour
garder son argent sur soi mais pas trop
de liquide qui est bien évidemment ses
papiers et puis il ne faut rien avoir de
précieux dans notre sac à dos ne pas se
faire voler quoi
enfin on verra bien tom payne n'a aucune
envie de se retrouver à la une des
médias chinois
les attaques de touristes à paris tourne
en boucle
un vin rouge local 23 touristes chinois
de la province de jiangsu se sont fait
agresser dans la banlieue de paris
ça s'est passé deux heures seulement
après leur arrivée écoutez le guide
il est encore sous le choc quand je me
suis rendu compte de leur arrivée j'ai
voulu protéger mon sac ont tous les
passeports sont là dedans les agresseurs
m'ont battu à terre ils m'ont donné des
coups de pieds ils m'ont traîné la
bandoulière du sac a cassé et ils l'ont
pris avec 7000 euros en liquide
le lendemain matin
no 26 touristes ont ces images en tête
lorsque paris est enfin à portée
d'objectifs les champs elysées est le
premier site qu'il visite
allez tous ensemble les garçons derrière
les filles devant
[Musique]
dix minutes sur place pas plus selon
tiancheng c'est trop risqué
c'est pas bon et très dangereux les
champs elysées et puis il n'ya pas que
les pickpockets il ya aussi les arnaques
vous savez le coût de la fausse bague en
or jeté par terre si vous la ramasse et
ils vous demandent de l'argent à croire
que la plus belle avenue du monde est
devenue la plus dangereuse plus de
descente des champs elysées au programme
ces derniers mois cheng a modifié le
parcours
direction la tour eiffel de loin venez
venez on est pressé mais la séance photo
sur le champ de mars va tourner court
à peine descendu du car quelques mètres
plus loin
ces femmes qui font la manche vont
encore faire peur à nos touristes
il n'est plus question d'aller sous la
tour eiffel et fait attention à ton gros
il ya des voleurs roumains près de la
station métro
ah mince oui ils sont juste là écoutez
il ya des voleurs par ici on reviendra
après
sur le même rythme effréné il y aura le
louvre et notre dame en 1h30
puis le château de versailles dans la
foulée en 45 minutes
il faut laisser le maximum de temps au
clou de la visite la séance shopping qui
va durer quatre heures
ces cadres ordinaire d'une société de
travaux publics ont un budget démesuré
8000 euros en moyenne
une partie de cet argent leur a été
confié par des proches pour qu'ils leur
apportent les articles des plus grandes
marques pour vous une montre à deux ou
trois mille euros ce n'est pas cher mais
ici pour les français comme ce chauffeur
c'est très cher donc nous montrer pas
que vous êtes riche pas de billets de
500 euros dans la main fait profil bas
beaucoup de gens peuvent se dire qu'est
ce qui se passe a parié il ya un
sentiment antichinois ou quoi les
agresseurs cible les chinois c'est vrai
on est une cible